welcome back to understanding Quantum information and computation my name is John watus and I'm the technical director for education at IBM Quantum
this is the 13th lesson of the series and it's the first lesson in the fourth and final unit which is on Quantum error
correction Quantum Computing has the potential to enable efficient solutions to computational tasks for which
efficient classical algorithms are not known and possibly don't exist there are however very significant challenges that
will need to be overcome if were to implement the sorts of large scale Quantum computations that we hope will one day be
possible the heart of the matter is that Quantum information is extremely fragile you can literally ruin it just by
looking at it and so to operate correctly quantum computers need to isolate the quantum information they
store from the environment around them to an extreme degree but at the same time the quantum computer itself must provide us with
very precise control over this Quantum information and that includes proper initialization accurate and reliable
unitary operations and of course the ability to perform measurements so that we can actually obtain the results of the
computation there's clearly some tension between these requirements and in the early days of quantum Computing there were some who viewed that the fragility
of quantum information and its susceptibility to both inaccuracies and environmental noise would ultimately
make Quantum Computing impossible today there's little doubt that building an accurate and reliable
large scale quantum computer is a Monumental challenge but we have a key tool to help us in this endeavor that leads most
people who are knowledgeable about the field to be optimistic about large scale Quantum Computing one day becoming a reality and that tool is quantum error
correction for the next four lessons we'll discuss Quantum error correction with a focus on the
fundamentals in this lesson we'll take a first look at Quantum error correction including one of the very first quantum
error correcting codes discovered the 9 Cubit Shore code and we'll also discuss another fundamental Concept in Quantum
error correction which is known as the discretization of errors in the subsequent lessons of the unit we'll see more sophisticated and ultimately better
Quantum error correcting code constructions and we'll also discuss the problem of quantum computation on encoded Quantum information using
computational components that are themselves not perfect and prone to errors here's a brief overview of the
lesson we'll Begin by discussing classical repetition codes which are perhaps the simplest and most basic type
of classical error correcting code classical repetition codes aren't particularly good codes by classical
coding Theory standards at least on their own but that's okay here we're going for Simplicity and in particular
we'll take a look at just about the simplest classical error correcting code you can possibly imagine which we'll then use as a basis for a simple example
of a Quantum error correcting code that example is the 9 cbit Shore code which we'll discuss in detail
including a description of the code itself as well as procedures for encoding cubits using this code detecting errors on encoded cubits and
correcting those errors and in the third part of the lesson we'll discuss the discretization of Errors which allows us to think about arbitrary errors on
cubits which in principle form a Continuum of possibilities in discrete terms essentially boiling errors down to
so-called bit flips and phase flips before we get into the Technic details of quantum error correction it's
worth taking just a moment to consider the need for Quantum error correction as well as classical error
correction as I suggested at the start of the lesson quantum computers are highly susceptible to errors owing to
the fragility of quantum information in particular unwanted interactions with the environment or in
other words the rest of the world can disturb Quantum information these unwanted interactions can cause decoherence where information
essentially leaks into the environment causing the information stored by the quantum computer to behave more and more
classically it's also critically important that we recognize that Quantum operations can only be performed with limited
accuracy for example we might wish to perform a particular Quantum gate on a cubit but because physical devices are
never perfect what we actually Implement might be just an approximation to that gate that might not be a big deal for a
single gate but if Our intention is to perform thousands or millions of quantum Gates these small inaccuracies will
start to acrew and when the computation is finished we could end up with a very different state from what we
expected so this is a rather different source of errors but it's certainly one that we can't
ignore people have been studying classical error correcting codes for close to a century and these codes have many applications including in
information transmission and storage but because classical Computing components are so reliable we we don't actually
need error correction to build classical computers now it might be the case that error correction isn't actually needed
to build reliable large scale quantum computers either for example the main idea behind topological Quantum
Computing is that it might be possible to build robust Quantum systems that are inherently protected against noise due
to topological properties of the systems but we don't know if this will be possible and it's pretty widely believed
that error correction will probably be essential in one form or another for large- scale Quantum Computing now we'll discuss classical
repetition codes which form the basis for our first Quantum error correcting code the nine cbit Shore code which
we'll see shortly repetition codes are extremely basic examples of error correcting codes
the idea is that we can protect bits against errors by simply repeating each bit some number of times in particular let's take a look at
the three-bit repetition code here we encode one bit into three by simply repeating the bit three times so
zero is encoded as 00 0 and one is encoded as 111 of course if nothing goes wrong we
can easily distinguish the two possibilities but if there was an error and one of the bits flipped let's say
meaning that a zero changes into a one or a one changes into a zero then we can still figure out what the original bit
was by seeing which of the two binary values appears twice equivalently we can decode by Computing the majority value
or in other words the binary value that appears most frequently and it's not hard to see that
if we have at most one bit flip error then the decoding will be correct of course if two bits Flip or if
all three bits flip then it won't work and we'll get the wrong value when we decode and that's a general property
that every error correcting code possesses you may be able to correct some errors but you'll never be able to correct every error and ultimately it's
about decreasing the chance of an error as opposed to guaranteeing correctness which is generally not
possible as an example of a situation in which we can decrease the chance of making an error let's suppose that our
goal is to communicate a single bit to a hypothetical receiver and to do this we're able to transmit bits through a
so-called binary symmetric Channel which flips each bit sent through it independently with some probability
P so with probability 1 minus P the receiver will get whichever bit we intended to send but with probability P
the bit flips and the receiver gets the opposite value to whatever we sent so if we don't use the repetition
code and instead we just send whatever bit we have in mind through the channel the receiver will get the wrong bit with
probability p on the other hand if we first encode the bit we want to send using the three-bit repetition code and
then send each of the three bits of the encoding through the channel then each one of them flips with probability P so
the chances of a bit flip are now greater because there are now three bits that could possibly flip rather than one
but if at most one of the bits flips then the receiver will be able to correctly decode so we'll only get an error after
decoding if two or more of the bits flip during transmission and it's not too hard to calculate that this happens with
probability 3 * P ^2 - 2 * P Cub for values of P smaller than 1/ 12
this leads to a decrease in the probability that the receiver ends up with the wrong bit there will still be a chance of an error in this case but the
code decreases the likelihood of this and if you wanted to decrease the chance even further you could do that using a
different code including but not limited to the possibility of using a repetition code where the encoded bit is repeated
more than three times for values of P greater than 1/ 12 by by the way the code actually makes
things worse in the sense that it increases the likelihood that the receiver gets the wrong bit so we would certainly not use this code in that
situation the three-bit repetition code is a classical error correcting code but we can also consider what happens if we
try to use it to protect cubits against errors it's not a very good Quantum error correcting code as we'll see it
can correct against some errors but it makes other errors more likely it is however the first step toward the shore
code so let's see how it works for cubits first to be clear when we refer to the 3-bit repetition code being used
for cubits what we have in mind is an encoding of a cubit as is shown on the screen where Alpha 0 plus beta 1 is
encoded as Alpha 0000 0 plus beta 111 or in other words the standard basis state
is repeated three times notice in particular that this is not the same thing as repeating the quantum state three times as in a given
Quantum state s being encoded as s tensor s tensor s which is not an encoding that we would be able to
implement for an unknown Quantum State s by the no cloning theorem the encoding that we're talking
about on the other hand is very easily implemented here's a very simple Quantum circuit that does it using two initialized workspace cubits and two
controlled knot Gates now let's suppose that an error takes place after the encoding has been
performed and in particular let's suppose that a polyx operation or in other words a bit flip happens on one of
the cubits and in this figure it's the middle Cubit of course this isn't the only sort of error that could occur and you might
object to the idea that an error takes the form of this perfect unitary operation but we'll come back to this later in the lesson and for now we can
just think about it as an example here's the resulting State it's the same as the original encoding except
that the middle bit within each K has been flipped obviously we can see this from the mathematical expressions for the state
but suppose that we only had the three cubits and that we suspected that a bit flip might have occurred but we didn't know which Cubit might have been
affected one way to figure out if a bit flip occurred would be to perform a standard basis measurement and examine the outcome in this case we would see
either 0 one0 or one one with probabilities depending on Alpha and beta and in either case our conclusion
would be that the middle bit flipped but unfortunately that ruins the original Quantum State and this state
might be precious to us after all the whole point is to protect this Quantum state so this is not a good
option what we can do instead is to use the quantum circuit shown here on the screen where we feed the encoded State
into the top three cubits basically what the circuit does is to compute the parity of the standard
basis States for the top two cubits as well as for the bottom two cubits of the encoding and and this will reveal the
location of the bit flip in particular in this case we'll get the outcome one for both of these parody checks and from
that information we can conclude that it's the middle bit that's different from the other two so that's evidently the one that
flipped and crucially this does not cause the state to collapse so we now have a chance to try to correct this bit
flip so that eventually we can perhaps decode and get our original state back we'll come back to the correction
in a moment but first let's briefly consider the other possibilities for a bit flip error If instead the bit flip error
occurred on the bottom or left Mouse Cubit then we would get the outcome one Zer reading from bottom to top and again
the state wouldn't change and if the bit flip happened to the top Cubit then the output would be
01 and once again the state doesn't change and by the way if there was no
bit flip error at all then the measurement outcome is 0 0 and once again the state comes out unchanged
so let's summarize all this in the form of a table where we list each of the possible states that we obtain from at most one bit flip the measurement
outcomes which we refer to as the syndrome in the context of error correction and the correction we need to make in order to get the original
encoding back if there was no error the syndrome is z Zer and nothing needs to be done to fix the
state if the bottom or leftmost Cubit experience to bit flip the syndrome is one Zer and the appropriate correction
is to apply an xgate to the bottom or leftmost Cubit and the other two cases are
similar so if we apply the appropriate correction based on the syndrome then we'll be certain to recover the original
encoding in all four cases once again we're only considering the possibility that at most one bit
flip error occurred this wouldn't work correctly if two or three bits flipped and we also haven't considered the
possibility of other errors now let's consider a different type of error in the quantum setting bit
flip errors aren't the only errors that we need to worry about for instance we also have to worry about phase flip
errors or just phase flips for short which are described by Z Gates or equivalently poly Z
operations unfortunately the three-bit repetition code completely fails to detect phase flips for instance supposing that we
encode a cubit using the 3-bit repetition code just like before and a phase flip error occurs on the middle
Cubit we'll obtain the state that's shown on the screen which is exactly the encoding that we would have gotten if a
phase flip had happened to the original Cubit before we encoded and so if we perform the same
circuit as before to try to detect an error we would get the syndrome z0 which wrongly suggests that no errors took
place so the 3 bit repetition code works for at most one bit flip error but it fails to detect phase flip errors in
fact it actually makes things worse in some sense because now we have three times as many cubits that could potentially experience phase flip
errors we've observed that the three-bit repetition code is completely oblivious to phase flip errors so it doesn't seem
to be very helpful for dealing with this sort of error but in fact we can modify the three- bit repetition code so that it
does detect phase flip errors and I'll explain now how this can be done here's the original circuit for
encoding a cubit using the 3-bit repetition code and the way that we'll modify it is very simple we just apply a
hadamar gate to each Cubit of the encoding a hadamar gate transforms a zero State into a plus State and a one
state into a minus state so the net effect is that we obtain the state that's shown on the screen where cat
Plus+ plus and Cat minus- minus are shorthand notation for the tensor of three plus States or three minus
States a face flip error or in other words a zgate transforms plus States into minus States and minus States into
plus States so this encoding will be useful for detecting and correcting phase flip errors and to do that we can
modify the error detection circuit from before in the following way here's the circuit from before and what we'll do is
simply to put hadamar gates at both the beginning and the end as is shown on the screen
the idea is very simple the first three hadamar gates transform plus and minus States back into zero and one States the
same parody checks us before take place and then the second layer of hadamar gates brings us back to our
encoding another way of thinking about this is that we're basically just transforming phase flip errors into bit flip Errors By conjugating by hatar
operations we can by the way simplify the circuit just a little bit this circuit here is completely equivalent
and you can check this for yourself if you're so inclined so if we put our encoda Cubit into this circuit assuming
no face flip errors have occurred we get the syndrome 0 0 indicating that there were no phase flip
errors and if we do have a phase flip error on the top Cubit let's say then the rightmost pluses and minuses flip
and that results in a different error syndrome 01 in this case that identifies the location of the phase flip just like
we had for bit flip and we can then correct it by applying a zgate to the top Cubit and the situation
is similar for face flip errors on either of the other two cubits so we can in fact detect and
correct up to one phase flip error using this code but unfortunately as you may have guessed we can now no longer
correct bit flip errors all is not lost however because we can in fact combine these two codes
together to obtain a code that can correct both bit flip and fade flip errors and in fact it will be able to
correct for any error on a single Cubit it's now time to discuss the 9 Cubit Shore code which is a Quantum
error correcting code that we can obtain by combining together the two codes that we just saw meaning the three bit
repetition code that allows us to correct a single bit flip error and the modified version of that code that allows us to correct a single phase flip
error to be more precise the 9 Cubit sh code is the code that we obtain by concatenating the two codes which means
that we first apply one encoding which encodes one cubit into three and then we apply the other encoding to each of the
three cubits separately so we'll get nine cubits in total we can express this in the form of
a circuit diagram as follows first we'll apply the modified version of the 3-bit repetition code
that detects phase flip errors and then we'll encode each of the resulting cubits independently using the original
3-bit repetition code so if we shrink this circuit down just a little bit to make some more room we can
specify the code in somewhat different terms by describing how the two standard basis States for our original Cubit get
encoded and once we know this we can determine by linearity how an arbitrary Cubit State Vector gets
encoded so that is the 9 Cubit Shore code and the idea is that one of the codes allows us to correct phase flip
errors and the other code allows us to correct bit flip errors and as we'll see that will in fact imply that we can
correct an arbitrary error on a single Cubit now let's see how we can detect and correct errors using the N9 Cubit
Shore code starting with bit flip errors which are also called X errors here's the circuit that performs
the encoding and just to make it easier to talk about we'll think about the nine cubits we get from this code as being
grouped into three blocks of three cubits where each block represents the encoding that we get from applying the
second encoding step which is the ordinary 3-bit repetition code that's called the inner code in
this context whereas the outer code is the code used for the first encoding step which in this case is the modified
version of the three-bit repetition code that works for phase flip errors to correct bit flip errors we can
simply treat each of the blocks separately each block is an encoding of a qbit using the three-bit repetition
code and that code protects against bit flip errors suppose first that an X error occurs on any one of the cubits
such as the middle cubit in the middle block if we independently check each of the blocks for bit flip errors and
correct for any errors we find then this error will be corrected and the original encoding will be
recovered in fact we could even have multiple X errors and still correct them in this way provided that the errors are
in separate blocks if we had two or three x errors in a single block we'd be in trouble but
as long as there's at most One X error per block the inner code will catch them and we'll be able to recover the original encoded
state so correcting bit flip errors is a pretty simple matter for this code we also need to consider phas flip errors
or in other words Z errors this time it's not quite so clear what we should do because the outer code is the one
that corrects for phase flip errors but we can't directly detect and correct them because the inner code is somehow
in the way but we'll see how to do this shortly to better understand how x and z
errors work and the effects that they have within Quantum circuits it's helpful to observe a few simple relationships between these errors and c
not Gates and this will also be helpful in a later lesson first let's start with X errors
or X Gates and how they relate to C not Gates if we apply an X gate to the
Target Cubit of a cot and then apply the C notot then that's equivalent to swapping the order and doing the cot
first on the other hand if we apply an xgate to the control Cubit of a cot and then apply the cot we can't simply
switch the order but instead we have to apply the xate to both cubits and you can check all of these relationships on
your own if you wish by thinking about what happens to standard basis States for instance the situation is similar for Z
errors except that the roles of the control and Target cubits switches in particular if we perform a
zgate on the control Cubit of a c knot and then perform the C knot then that has the same effect as performing the
zgate after the C notot but if we perform the zgate on the target Cubit instead then that's
equivalent to first performing the cot and then applying a zgate to both cubits and finally all of these
relationships are symmetric in the sense that we can always swap The Ordering of the gates on both sides of each equation
which is equivalent to taking the inverse or the conjugate transpose of both sides given that x z and c not
gates are all their own inverses now let's consider phase flip errors and how we can detect and correct
them using the 9 Cubit Shore code here's our encoding circuit and we'll continue to think about the nine
cubits used in the encoding as being grouped into three blocks of three cubits suppose that a z error occurs on
any one of the cubits such as the one indicated here using what we just observed about Z
Gates and cot Gates that's equivalent to two Z errors prior to the cot one on the
control and one on the target Cubit and these errors happen to commute with the other cot in the block so we
can swap the ordering and here's what we obtain the lower Z error doesn't do anything because it's acting on a zero
State and we can slide everything else over and obtain this diagram so what we found is that a z a ER somewhere within
the middle block is equivalent to a z error occurring on the middle Cubit prior to the second encoding phase and
you can reason exactly the same thing for a z error on any of the cubits a phase flip on any Cubit within a block
is equivalent to a phase flip on the corresponding Cubit prior to the inner encoding and that's actually pretty straightforward and intuitive if you
think about how zrs affect the three-bit repetition code so one option for dealing with a z
error is to decode the inner code and then detect and correct Z errors using the outer code which is the modified
version of the 3-bit repetition code that can correct for a z error so that corrects our Z error and
we could re-encode with the inner code if we wanted to do that we can also correct Z errors in
place so to speak without decoding and then re-encoding and it's pretty straightforward but to explain how we
can do that we'll need a little bit more space suppose that we decode the inner code
and then we compute the syndrome for the outer code using the same method as before where we're only involving the three cubits from the outer code and
then we re-encode well we can simplify all of these cots just a little bit and in fact
we can use the relationships between not Gates and cot Gates that we just observed a few moments ago to help with that
task and by doing this we can save four cots and this is the circuit that we obtain if a z error has occurred on one
of the cubits what the syndrome tells us now is not which Cubit experienced a z error but rather which block the Z error
happened in but that's okay because we know that it doesn't matter which Cubit within a block experiences a z error the
effect is the same for all three cubits within that block and so we can in fact correct the Z error by applying a zgate to any of
the cubits within that block this by the way is an example of what's called degeneracy in an error
correcting code where we don't uniquely identify a given error but we're able to correct it anyway finally let's suppose that both a
bit flip and a face flip error occur possibly on the same Cubit for example let's suppose that a
bit flip and a face flip error happens on this cubbit right here as it turns out these errors can be
detected and corrected completely independently and in fact it doesn't matter if we correct each block for a
bit flip first and then correct for phas flips or if we do it the other way around to see this let's first observe
that the ordering of these errors doesn't matter so we can flip them around if we wish the reason for that is not because
x and z commute because they don't x * Z is equal to negative Z * X but the
negative 1 Factor has no effect in this situation because it's a global phase we can now move the Z error just like
before and at this point it's evident that if we were first to correct each block for X errors and then we corrected
for Z errors we would then have corrected both errors alternatively if for some reason
we decided to correct for Z erors first we could do that and the XR has absolutely no effect in that process
that has to be true because number one the X error commutes with every single gate in the circuit that computes the
syndrome for the outer code and number two the ordering between the X eror and the zgate that we apply to make the
correction doesn't matter just like we argued when the zgate was an error so that allows for the correction of the Z
error and we can then correct each block to eliminate the X error so what we've argued is that we
can correct an X error a z error or both on any one of the cubits using this code
in fact we can correct for more errors than that such as multiple X errors as long as they fall into different blocks
or multiple Z errors as long as at most one block gets an odd number of them but going forward what will be most relevant
is that we can correct an X error a z error or both on any one cubit and in the last part of the lesson
we'll see how this is in fact enough to conclude that this code can correct for an arbitrary error on any one
cubit before we move on to the last part of the lesson in which we'll consider arbitrary Quantum errors we'll briefly
consider the performance of the N Cubit short code when errors represented by poly metrices occur randomly on the
cubits to be more concrete let's consider a simple noise model where errors occur independently on the cubits
with each Cubit experiencing an error with probability p and with no correlation between errors on different
cubits the worst case scenario for the 9 Cubit sh code is that a y error or in other words both an X error and a z
error occurs on each of fected Cubit and we'll assume this worst case scenario just for the sake of obtaining a bound
on the code's performance but you could also consider for instance that the three poly errors are equally
likely now suppose that Q is a cubit in some particular state that we'd like to protect against errors and imagine that
we have the option to use the 9 Cubit Shore code should we use it well the answer is not necessarily
yes because if there's two much noise or in other words p is too large using the shore code could actually make things
worse just like we had for the repetition code when p is larger than 1/2 but if p is small enough then the
answer is yes we should use the code so let's see why this is and what it means for p to be too large or small
enough for this code the shore code can correct any poly error on a single Cubit and in the worst
case where are poly errors are y errors this means that the code successfully protects Q with a probability given by
the expression shown on the screen specifically the code works when there are no errors and that happens
with probability 1 minus p ^ 9 because there are nine cubits that must each be unaffected and it works when there's
exactly one error and considering that there are nine different cubits that could possibly be affected this happens with probability 9 * P * 1 - p ^ 8
on the other hand if we didn't bother using the code our one and only Cubit would be unaffected by an error with
probability one minus P so the code only helps when the first probability is larger than the second
because these Expressions represent our probabilities of success in the two cases when we use the code and when we
don't here's a plot of these two functions for small values of p and we find that the break even Point occurs at
about 3 and a/4 per. so if p is smaller than this value then the code
helps at the break even point the probabilities are equal so we're just wasting our time along with 8 cubits if
we use the code but otherwise there's no harm in it and beyond that point we should absolutely not be using this code
because it's actually increasing the chance of an error on the encoded Cubit which we typically refer to as the
logical cubit in this context and that's happening simply because the chance of two or more errors on nine cubits is
larger than the chance of one error on a single Cubit for values of p in this range 3 and a/ qu% may not seem very
good particularly when compared to 50% which is the analogous Break Even point for the three-bit repetition code for
classical information but it's harder to protect Quantum information and moreover although this
code represents a brilliant Discovery as the very first Quantum error correcting code and it happens to be great for pedagogical purposes the fact of the
matter is that it's just not all that good of a code in Practical terms so far we've considered X errors
and Z errors in the context of the 9 Cubit Shore code now let's consider arbitrary errors
starting first with unitary errors so for example such an error could correspond to a very small
rotation of the block sphere possibly representing an error that's incurred by a gate that isn't perfect for instance
or it could be any other unitary operation on a cubit and not necessarily something close to the identity
operation it might seem like correcting for such errors is difficult there are infinitely many possible errors like
this and it's inconceivable that we could somehow identify exactly what error it is and then undo it but we
don't actually need to do anything different from what we've already discussed as long as we can correct for a bit flip a phase Flip or both then we
will in fact suc succeed in correcting for an arbitrary single Cubit unitary error and I'll now explain why that
is first like all 2x two matrices we can express an arbitrary unitary Matrix
representing an error on a single Cubit as a linear combination of the four poly matrices including the identity
Matrix and by the way as you may have noticed I'm using capital X Y and Z to denote the non-identity polym matrices
and I'll continue to do that for the remainder of this series that's conventional in Quantum error correction and it also makes
things a bit easier to read in this context it's also going to be convenient to use subscripts to indicate which
Cubit a given Cubit unitary operation acts on so for example if we use Kit's
Cubit numbering convention starting from Cubit zero on the right then we have the Expressions shown on the screen for
various unitary operations on single cubits where in each case we tensor the unitary Matrix with the identity Matrix
on every other Cubit so in particular we can express UK meaning U applied to Cubit K as the same
linear combination as before except that each poly Matrix is applied to Cubit K we don't need to bother with the
subscript for the identity by the way the understanding here is that this is the identity on all the
cubits now suppose that SII is the 9 Cubit encoding of a cubit state if the the error U happens to
Cubit k then we obtain u k * s which we can express as a linear combination of poly operations acting on S which of
course is just s in the case of the identity at this point it's going to be helpful to observe that the poly y
Matrix is equal to I * x * Z so we can make that substitution in our
expression so this error has taken place and now suppose that we attempt to correct it using the same procedure as
four the first step is to compute the syndrome which in the case of the sh code is 8 Bits long two bits for each of
the three times we use the inner code along with an additional two bits for the outer code but it doesn't really matter we can just think about it as
some fixed length string here's a description of the state that we get just prior to the measurement of the syndrome where each
syndrome is whatever eight bits we get from the corresponding poly error notice at this point that the two
systems are Cor ated in general and really this is the key to making all of this work by measuring the syndrome what
we'll effectively do is to collapse the state into one where one of the four poly operations has been applied to the
Ki cubi of sigh and we'll know from the syndrome which poly operation it was so we can correct it if
needed in particular if we measure the syndrome and make the appropriate correction then we obtain a state of the
form shown on the screen which critically is a product State we have our original uncorrupted encoding as the
right- hand tensor factor which is what is most important here and on the left we have a density Matrix s that
describes a random error syndrome but there's no longer any correlation with the system that we care about which is
the one on the right because the errors have been corrected at this point we can throw the syndrome cubits away or reset them in
case we want to use them again and that's actually pretty important because this is how the randomness or entropy
generated by errors is removed from the system and that's how the discretization of Errors works at least for unitary
errors in essence by measuring the syndrome we effectively project the error onto an error that's described by
a poly Matrix at first glance it may seem too good to be true that we can correct for arbitrary unitary errors
like this even errors that are tiny and hardly noticeable on their own but what's important to realize here
is that this is a un error on a single Cubit and by the design of the code a single Cubit operation cannot change the
state of The Logical Cubit that's being encoded all it can possibly do is to move the state out of the space of valid
encodings but then the corrections bring it right back to where it was finally let's consider what happens
when an arbitrary not necessarily unitary error occurs the setup is the same as before
we've encoded one cubit into 9 using the short code and some arbitrary error represented by a cubit Channel thi
occurs on one of the cubits as we'll see everything is going to work out in pretty much the same way
as it did for unitary errors and the first step toward verifying this is to consider a cross representation of our
error what we can do now is to follow exactly the same reasoning as for unitary errors except that we apply that
reasoning to the Cross matrices rather than to a single unitary Matrix representing an error
in particular each cruss Matrix can be expressed as a linear combination of poly matrices and this allows us to
express the action of this error fi on whatever cubic K it happens to in the form that's shown here on the
screen all we're really doing here is to expand out the cross matrices as linear combinations of poly
matrices if we then compute and measure the error syndrome and correct for any errors that are revealed we'll obtain a
similar sort of state to what we had in the case of a unitary error I won't go through the details it's all quite similar to the unitary
case and also a little bit Messier to write down but conceptually speaking it's pretty
straightforward I should mention that this all generalizes to other Quantum error correcting codes including codes that can correct for errors on multiple
cubits in such a case errors on multiple cubits can be expressed as linear combinations of tensor products of poly
matrices and corresponding ly the different possible syndromes will describe Corrections that are performed on multiple cubits rather than just one
cubit but the underlying idea is exactly the same again by measuring the syndrome
we effectively project or collapse errors into a discrete set of possibilities represented by tensor
products of poly metrices and by correcting those errors meaning the poly errors we can recover the original
encoded State meanwhile whatever Randomness is generated in the process is moved into the syndrome cubits which we can then
discard or reset which is crucial because that's how the entropy generated by errors and syndrome measurements is
removed from the system and that is the end of the lesson in which we've taken a first look at
Quantum error correction including the 9 Cubit Shore code and the discretization of Errors I hope you will join me for the
next lesson in which we'll discuss the stabilizer formalism which provides us with a powerful tool for describing and
analyzing a large and interesting class of quantum error cting codes including ones that are promising candidates for
real quantum computers goodbye until then